we hear from the left and we hear from
the squish republicans they say oh just
mind your own business
just hey if that guy wants to make a
nuisance of himself in popeye's mind
your own business well
those guys in popeyes were minding their
own business but that guy wouldn't let
them mind their own business samantha b
just made this point
you don't think that a man should wear
stilettos mind your own business
this year we're seeing a tidal wave of
transphobic legislation targeting kids
largely in retaliation for president
biden's executive order to protect
trans rights conservatives are staging a
coordinated attack on trans kids by
making up a problem that absolutely
doesn't exist
most of the legislators who sponsored
anti-trans bills this year can't even
cite a single instance where trans girls
competing in sports has caused problems
rather these laws stem from the very
incorrect misconception that trans women
are not women
they falsely claim trans women
automatically have more testosterone and
therefore more muscle mass than cis
women
but studies don't show a consistent
relationship between testosterone
and athletic performance so why are
conservatives actually targeting trans
athletes
fear-mongering baby just like with the
bathroom bills republicans are trying to
scare their base into voting for people
like
governor if life didn't go well pat
sajak let's be real
conservatives don't actually care about
this they just want to politically
profit from
excluding trans people from yet another
public space
at the end of the day republicans need
to stop policing other people's bodies
mind their own
business and let trans people live their
lives yeah just
mind your own business so obviously the
factual claim she's making are just
completely wrong the idea that there's
no evidence that there's ever been an
athletic issue here there's a court
there's a case at the supreme court
right now
that's working its way up the courts
that the alliance defending freedom is
working on i think we've talked about it
on the daily wire quite a lot so yes it
has happened
many times the idea that
the anti-anti-trans bills are infringing
on trans rights no the question is what
is the
definition of a person these republicans
they don't really care about this
they just they just want to harm people
they just want to
you should just mind your own business
we are minding our own business why
don't you mind your own business
samantha b
mind your own business we're here we've
been in this society now and in
civilization for i don't know um
ever you know just about forever we've
we've
been from primitive man all the way up
to
this alleged height of civilization that
we're living through right now
we have always at all times everywhere
believe that men are men and women are
women so
just mind your own business and if you
you disagree with that reality then
just stop pushing this on me but this
has nothing to do that
this has nothing to do with minding your
own business this has everything to do
with
with dominating the business with
declaring
the rules of engagement with defining
the standards
what you know you always hear this well
hey
get get your get your morality out of my
politics
well your samantha b's imposing her
morality on our politics get your
religion out of my pocket you're
imposing your religion on my politics
your religion says a man can be a woman
my religion says it can't
only one of those religions is going to
win out and i think it ought to be mine
because mine's correct
so and everyone has agreed with that for
all of human history until about five
seconds ago
you can't just keep these things private
and conservatives worse than
leftists almost have given into this
idea well just leave me alone get off my
lawn yeah
that goes only so far as
the force of law comes in and tells you
that you
your world view is no longer permissible
and that's the point that we're at right
now
oh hello there oh i barely noticed you
came in
you might not notice that i come in to
your computer if you don't ring that
bell if you don't like and you subscribe
because then you won't get the
notifications youtube already
doesn't want you to see the videos that
we put out so make sure you ring the
bell right now
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you